hello everybody my name is naya and i'm
the black female engineer
i provide content for new and aspiring
software engineers
and today is very exciting because we're
talking about
money we're talking about that cash
and really just going into salary and
offer negotiations so
let's get to it actually before i
get to it i need to just i need to just
put this disclaimer out that i
am not a professional mentor i'm not
you know uh licensed anything i am just
sharing my own tips and advice from my
own teachings my own
experience and hope that you can add any
of these things
to your toolkit to help you out in the
future
so keep that in mind okay
now let's get to it so first things
first you got the job
congratulations that is something that's
super exciting and
worth celebrating no matter what because
it's hard y'all up in the street it's
it's hard
so congratulations so they gave you
you know they said we are looking to
hire you we would love to give
you this offer first things first
never and i mean never accept an offer
over the phone i don't care if they
offer you five hundred thousand dollars
do not accept an offer over the phone
simply
say thank you and you know acknowledge
you know the
time y'all have spent together
interviewing and everything
and hang up that phone and and
wait for the official package or
anything to come or just give yourself
time to think about things
next rule never ever be the first
to give numbers for what you're looking
for in your offer
if they ask you either before
you know the official interviews or
after you get the job because i've been
asked you know even during app applying
or during my first interview
do not give them a straight answer when
asked
what are you looking for in terms of
compensation in terms of salary
what i say and y'all might drag me for
this what i say
is well i'm looking for whatever is fair
and equitable given the position company
and
location of this opportunity
that is it that's all i say because
no way am i going into this trap of
being lowballed because i gave the wrong
number
so that is what i do now let's say
because some of these recruiters man
like will just keep on like
getting at you and everything what if
they say okay we understand that but we
need a number
okay give them a range i'm looking
for anything between 75
and 100 000 depending on location
and position
sorry not sorry because salary
isn't just the number you need to look
at so many different things to see what
actually
is a right salary seventy five thousand
dollars in nebraska is way different
than seventy five thousand dollars in
new york
heck seventy five thousand dollars in
nebraska is way different
than one hundred thousand dollars in new
york
in terms of you know actual cash you'll
get to see
nebraska is still better in terms of you
know
what you'll take home and you know live
the cost of living and all of this
so you need to do your research you need
to see where
is this position located and what is the
um like the average salary the average
compensation for somebody in my position
or in the position that i'm applying to
interviewing for
in this location that way when an
interviewer asks you
what you're looking for you give them oh
well given
the ranges i have seen through research
this range to this range is where i'd be
looking to start off negotiations
that is how you start off that process
now if we talk about what um resources
that are available for that research
glassdoor yo i use glassdoor like is
running out of style like i use
glassdoor
for everything and i have found it to be
very reliable
but um if you're looking for something a
lot more concrete
one great great resource is levels.fyi
i'll link those two below along with
some
more but levels.fyi is great
because they go through a very robust um
confirmation process in making sure that
what you're reporting is your salary for
this one company or this one location
is correct and accurate and you're not
lying you're not you know
doing anything wild so they you can
really really trust those numbers
so i highly recommend those resources
again i'll link them below
but make sure you do that research so
that
they know you can't just be hoodwinked
and swindled when you know
that this company paid their last 10
engineers 200 000
meanwhile they're offering you 64 000
like
no so going into negotiations
so first make sure this is face to face
or you know because of this panda bear
make sure
it is green to screen because it's a lot
easier to have true
genuine and honest conversations that
way and
by doing that you can look out for
non-verbal
cues you can look out for you know if
they are
you know look in some type of way if
they're you know hesitating or
everything you can see that a lot better
by you know
webcams i feel old saying that i think
that's the right term
um by you know zoom in all of those
those types of meetings
do not do email and if you can stay away
from it don't do phone calls seriously
do a face-to-face
screen to screen conversation so
they say we are so excited to offer you
this position here is the salary we
would have you for
so you see the salary
i you'll see um different
uh advice on this i personally have
never negotiated right there and then
after seeing the salary i've never just
said hold up i want
x y and z i've never done that instead
i've been like okay thank you
um i just need you know give me one day
and i'll get back to you
then in that day i am talking to
everybody and their mama trying to make
sure
i get a whole picture of this company a
whole picture of um
their previous you know salary history
and you know things like the previous
research i talked about
bonus points if you can find somebody
who
has worked at that company or has worked
in your position
to give you their numbers as to what
they get paid
this just provides some insight into
what's realistic and what's not this is
something i
personally very much encourage
especially amongst you know
us women and us people of color that is
something i very very much encourage
and so try to seek um
someone out to just give you who also
you know works
at the position it doesn't have to be
the same company but who also works
in the same type of position you are
looking to work in or you just got your
offer for
try to see what their numbers are don't
pressure them to tell you but if they
are willing then that would be great but
this one day passes and you say thank
you
you know amanda for this offer i'd love
to talk about
talk more in detail about it face to
face here's my
availability and schedule a meeting so
now you're in this meeting
and now it is time for you to bring
forth
like like a lawyer bring forth the
discovery
of these last few you know hours and
days
bring up the research you found so
saying
you offered me let's let's work with a
number it's easier to work with a number
let's say 85 000.
you offered me 85 000 however through my
research i saw that
the average salary range is between you
know 85 000 and 95
000 um i would like to see that number
go up to that
95 000 number and just a side note
if you are applying to a job or just you
know got hired for a job that is in a
different location
than you are now than than you
currently live in use a calculator to
see what the pay conversion is so
basically
let's say i got you know a job for los
angeles and
it's for eighty thousand dollars i
currently
let's say live in nebraska and i you
know have
i know what my rent looks like and i do
i use this calculator to see that in a
shoot what was the number i said was it
75 000 let's say it was 75 000.
i use the calculator to see that a 75
salary in california is equivalent to
a 42 000 salary in nebraska let's say
that's what it converts
i don't know if that's what it converts
to but let's say that's what it converts
to
now ask yourself would you accept a 42
000 salary in nebraska
would you if you would then you're in a
good spot but
would you and think about the type of
life you would have
with a 42 000 in salary in nebraska
and now think about that with california
that is the same type of life
you would have in terms of you know food
and going out and
rent and you know your flexibility or
inflexibility
so make sure you use this conversion and
make sure you bring this
up in your salary negotiation if this
applies to you
say look this is where i live this is
what you're offering me
and the conversion doesn't sit right
with me i want x amount of money to make
sure i sustain the life i'm currently
living now let's say they are first
like nah son nope you
you aren't qualified enough for this
type of pay or you know for this
pay enhancement well
y'all remember this don't ever
let a company tell you that you are not
worth x amount of money
they hired you do they not
they you know obviously saw your
qualifications
and saw that you were the right fit even
if let's say their
job description at first said they want
somebody with
four years of experience and you only
have two and a half or three years of
experience
and that's what they use to say oh
that's why we can't pay you x amount
but you still hired me so you're
obviously
you know knowing that
i am qualified and i am the person for
the job
because i did these type of projects i
put on these types of initiatives
and um in my two and a half years i've
done
these to the programs and that is
equivalent to what you would have wanted
to see someone with four years anyway
so remind them that be swift and smooth
to remind them that
but yes the next is making sure you
present your credentials and saying
why you are worth it why you are worth
in terms of technical skill
in terms of leadership experience and
also in terms of culture
and what you are hoping to see um
yourself
how you're hoping to see yourself grow
within this company so
let's say you did all of this and
they're like sorry like what we offered
you is our best offer
this may not be a lie sometimes
companies really do give their best
offer so don't think you're being you
know swindled or had ranked or anything
but there are other things to negotiate
other than just cash
you can negotiate vacation days flex
time you can negotiate
um education assistance along with stock
you can negotiate also the location
if you are if you apply to um a company
that gave a bunch of location ranges you
can negotiate the location you want to
be in
and you can negotiate the team you want
to work with or the technologies you
want to work with
if they just said you know oh full stack
developer or something
um you can say i want to specifically
work in the front end team
in you know with react with the back end
you can negotiate
all of these different things and when
you rack them up they can end up being
worth
the same or more than
the cash itself so make sure you
remember that
so look at okay what is something that i
would value
most of this list of things what is
something i would value
most would i value vacation days you
would i value work from home days you
know
the flexibility to work from home
especially if you're getting
this position you know during a pain to
bear you can say when it is back to
working in the office
i would still like the chance to work 50
from home
you can negotiate all of these things
and that could give you
better um luck in you know this whole
offer negotiation situation another
thing
that i just forgot to mention you can
also negotiate a sign-on bonus
so you can't get you know let's say you
can't get that extra five thousand ten
thousand
in your salary but let's say you can get
that five thousand
in a one-time bonus negotiate that
as well or if they already gave you it
ask for more
so just remember there are other things
you can
negotiate but at the end of it all if
you don't feel good about this
offer you can also negotiate the expert
of the offer so let's say they say
you have one week to accept a decline
ask
for three weeks if you know that you
have certain interviews coming up
or you apply to a job that you're
excited about and um are
you know hoping to hear back from them
soon you can ask for you know
three more weeks if they ask for why you
need three more weeks
be forthcoming be forthcoming but fake
um i like
something i like to say is well in three
weeks that's when i will have the
necessary information for me to
accept or deny this offer with
confidence and
usually most of the time they give you
some type of extension maybe not the
full three weeks
or the full time that you asked for that
they
most of the time are willing to work
with you then y'all
don't be afraid to then after you know
let's say they gave you
10 days instead of three weeks at the
end of those 10 days
ask for another 10 days
because here's the thing you have the
upper hand in this
companies spend so much money when it
comes to recruitment
that when they finally have somebody
that they want to hire
they they're not gonna just that's
something people are afraid of that the
company is just going to
be like you know what never mind and we
don't want to hire you anymore and
you know get that is not something that
you shouldn't be afraid of
and honestly if a company does do that
then you know that
they were going to drop you in the drop
of a hat anyway
you did not have job security anyway
because if asking
questions and asking for flexibility
makes them take away
your offer oh nah goodbye
goodbye so just keep
asking and so ask for extensions so you
can make sure that you're making
the best possible decision for you and
at the end of the day
if you know that you would feel
bad about yourself or feel sick at the
idea of walking into this office every
day
being paid what you end up being paid
then that is not a a company you should
accept that's not an offer you should
accept now of course people have
different circumstances in which
they have to accept certain things but
if you have the flexibility not to
give yourself you know say you know what
thank you for this experience thank you
for the interviews
i enjoyed meeting you but i have to
sadly or unfortunately decline
and just bet on yourself y'all that's
something that i
say all the time to people close to me
and you know
i'm saying to y'all bet on yourself
don't think that this is the only job
that's going to come around a company
will come
that sees your value and can match what
you see as your value
and then some so make sure that you at
the end of the day
are doing the best thing for you but
also for your peace of mind
but there we go everybody my tips for
offering negotiation
and if you like this video or like any
of the tips i shared
please click that subscribe button and
click that like button and
i look forward to seeing you all soon
but bye y'all